okay so today this is our second to last
day of Aristotle and now we're actually
getting into some things directly tied
to practical reasoning and we're getting
into some really murky topics this this
book it's particularly you notice
aerosol said several times alright I'll
make a fresh start here we'll make a
fresh start here then again I'm thinking
about it this way then again thinking
about that way and it may seem somewhat
confusing there is some stuff in here
that continues to attract scholars
attention in part because even the
scholars aren't sure when Aristotle
saying so if you found yourself as some
of you have expressed to me I am not
quite getting what's going on with
Aristotle it at different points if you
have any reason for that this is the
book this is the chapter where that's
the case so there are some things in
here where I'm just going to lecture
that sort of lay out what I think is
happening other parts where we're going
to do discussion this is the question
that I would like you to think about
that I'm going to call upon here for
examples of just to have some class
discussion what is something and don't
think anything that confident you would
actually get you in any sort of trouble
what is something that you've done
recently knowing that it was wrong
you haven't done anything recently
knowing that it was wrong pick something
that you did not so recently don't know
what it was I'm guessing everybody has
done some stuff I don't have to go that
far I could instead about the weekend
actually
so I mean nothing particularly juicy or
or spectacular but you know I am NOT
myself virtue is in every respect the
way I would like to be and I'm guessing
that most of you are in that situation
as well if you've fallen into that case
then you were what Aristotle calls
incontinent and so here here we need to
get something out of the way right the
terminology in this chapter will often
confuses people we talked about somebody
in our society being consonants are
incontinent we usually think about it
just with one sort of thing and it's
mainly
scatological you know Aristotle with the
people that are translating Aristotle
we're using the phrase of a somewhat
different sense what they're calling
continents and incontinence in Greek is
Katya and Mikasa and those mean things
sort of like strength of will and
weakness
or self-control and laughter something
so the continent person is somebody who
has self-control or the capacity to use
their their will to do this and make
themselves do what they know is right
the incontinent person is somebody who
know what the right thing is to do but
they something slips something doesn't
happen right and they find themselves
doing the wrong thing this is a common
experience throughout all of human
history you can look at any culture and
you will find some people who are soft
control in this sense and some people
who are not so there's one other term
that thankfully they translate this
brutality in this translation because
the other translations people who often
do it as bestiality again we associate
that with deviant sexual practices which
would actually fit into that category
three are slow but brutality means order
bestiality and Aristotle sense means
being like an animal being just like
eating because we are animals right we
eat we drink we have all sorts of drives
we move from place to place we you know
we share most of our DNA in common with
most other living things even worms we
have about 40%
get the chips it's about 98% so we're
pretty much animal we're not just
Aristotle whenever we talked about this
before talks about a higher rational
part Plato talked about this as well
that a lower appetite apartment so when
you have brutality
there isn't a higher part the higher
part is sort of disengaged and some of
the questions that you guys had earlier
in the semester about what about say
addictions that would fit into the
category when aerosols confer tell
because we're really holding the addict
responsible for the behavior of the
danger they do not because they're not
actually incontinent to business they
may actually totally we all have
experience with these hopefully not too
much with this people who are genuinely
brutal or extremely dangerous and you
should stay away from them because you
can't count on them you can't reason
with them you can't kind of them not to
follow their their appetites whatever
they you have any way trouble
Aristotle also does talk about one other
thing he talks about superheated virtue
and he doesn't mean like you know Batman
or spider-man if they actually just
played virtue of those movies it's more
like what we talked about is the virtues
in aerosol
when he talks about superhuman for issue
he is talking about what we might think
about our time as people that were
called Saints they're able to accomplish
something or moral exemplars they're
able to accomplish something that's on
scale of going beyond merely an ease not
going to talk about that much for the
rest of the chapter so where I'm going
to talk about a class I just want to
point out the death sort of thing does
exist but you know it's sort of of its
own danger it's sort of like in totality
there is no better part to the person
and so the worst parts predominate and
superhuman there is no longer any worse
there's nothing for them to control they
a lot of management that's very far from
our we're more likely and here or what
virtuous or vicious so let's look at
what he what he actually says he says
let's make a fresh beginning point out
of moral States there's these different
types and we could put these on us or a
continuum where think about virtualize
they're very separate from each other
right the virtuous person does the right
thing and they actually take pleasure in
doing the right thing they have the
mating habits the vicious person is the
opposite they do the wrong things
- well that could be that they dispense
as far as easily to people who run
business and it's a habit - and the
virtuous person thinks what they're
doing is right and the vicious person
actually does think what they're doing
is right
they just haven't a stinkin review about
that so these are pretty far apart from
each other consonants in consonants are
just here's breadth of a provision
what's the difference they're the
continent and the incompetent person
they both know what the right thing to
do is they're not like the vicious
person the consonant person chooses to
follow their conscience were to follow
reason for it follow the Barisal
cultivate moral principle thing that's
telling them hey this is the right thing
to do
the independent person in one way or
another allows something else to make
the decision for them and they wind up
doing the wrong thing okay all of you
are pretty familiar with us right you've
all been on both sides of this divide
how do you get from one side to the
other well you know if you can literally
try to make yourself do the right thing
pretty soon it becomes easier to become
confident and if you do it long enough
you will become virtuous right how do we
get virtues remember what makes searches
to do the the same virtue over and over
again as a habit and then eventually
don't you sinner
yeah so you do things like a virtuous
person you you behave justly towards
Savior
first you behave justly towards your
siblings then you behave justly towards
your fellow classmates and even here
justly towards people you don't know on
the train then you behave justly when
you're in the workplace and eventually
you become anything just person if you
are incontinent and you know the right
thing to do is when you keep on doing
the wrong thing at some point you're
likely to slip into vice that that sense
of I shouldn't have done that wasn't
wrong will eventually vanish Aristotle
says by you know we become what we do
another sort of famous slogan that goes
along with this is fake it till you make
it heard that before
maybe we'll get into other contexts you
know if you are confident you are yet
virtuous so let's take justice again
justice includes you know treating
people fairly maybe you don't want to
treat people fairly they prevent it in a
situation like that just like somebody
you'd like to cut them out you don't
want to invite them to the club meeting
or give them you know a portion of
something that you're supposed to or
they're part of your group and you're
supposed to do it creating exercise and
you just don't like it great and lower
they could choose not to if you choose
to do the right thing that's confidence
you're not yet virtuous but keep doing
that and eventually it will be
outrageous so remember back in last
Monday we talked about our choices and
how that goes into virtue our choices
are taking place for the most part not
at this law this is where we're actually
decided to be confident that eventually
the form of our character once your
virtuous it's easy to do the right thing
once you're vicious
it's actually easy to do the wrong thing
so he says we're going to distinguish
between what he calls incontinent in a
qualified sense and in qualified sense
in terms that he's using they're so
unqualified means sort of in general
without pianning anything to it you say
that somebody is a good person and you
don't say anything more you're calling
them good unquiet unqualifiedly if you
say that person is good for sports
you're really narrowing
is a tragedy or anything like that
you're saying they're great in sports
it's the same thing with it concerts so
let's now actually use some of these
news examples you've got a little bit of
time to think about times when you find
yourself failing morally doing things
who would like to I won't actually just
call them who would who would like to
volunteer some example thoughts ideas
something small
nobody can say you you coerced your
friend into telling the secret so this
is an interesting one because so when
you did you knew it wasn't the right
thing to do and the wrong thing for you
to do was to make somebody else do the
wrong thing so this is a kind of
complicated so then we haven't be able
to an example let's use your crash so
your friend hold the secret
we often call those you know small lies
or white lines or stuff like that right
here notice that one actually includes
the explanation of why did what you did
anything else
very very good
because you want aerosol I might say
that's not a dude if you're guaranteed
to win but let's say we'll call it
gambling I've got a friend actually
another philosophy professor who count
Starks
mr. Dantas is a professional gamblers
and she's actually been barred from from
some casinos they catch you they don't
like them
well let's work with these so this one
we already have the explanation of their
whole life to get out you need to that's
more avoiding pain that seeking pleasure
today or maybe due to a point that some
things that you're close to pleasure
pressuring a friend to tell us secret
why do we like people to tell secrets
maybe enjoy right we want to find out
even if you know what curiosity doesn't
have to be celebrity based most your
professors who are researchers something
they're curious about I guess or
pleasure of telling the secrets why
accredited to get the pressure that
you're getting or maybe pleasing you
I'm not revealing cheating so yeah so
you may in actually sort of made a
calculation will lose less this guy
because once you tell something else to
chew
the whole weekend this is going to be
about that right maybe even longer this
weekend I'm gambling it crudely there
would be a problem if you know you find
yourself not not able to control
yourself or you shouldn't do it oh well
that might be for the so maybe this
women beings we want something that
where you knew it was wrong but you did
it so we think about these these are all
pretty straightforward pretty you know
minor stuff I mean all these could
actually be any of yours are why do we
end up doing this or we experience a
kind of weakness or moment of indecision
or something else bringing us along and
for each one of these things you could
ask yourself could you have told
yourself no I'm going to do this I'm
going to follow through so the answer is
probably yes right and you can multiply
these sort of instances all the time in
the enterprise should I be more
courteous to people should I
follow up with with friends and I
haven't corresponding with for a while
should I be more conscious about how my
fiance is doing and ask her how she's
doing more often all sorts of things I'm
sure you know we can all find instances
like that why don't you do it well there
are other things going on there's
something else happening so that's where
we get what aerosol actually says
Aristotle thinks about this in a couple
different ways this is where it really
work his presentation just sort of all
over the map so I'm just gonna lay it
out for you semantically and then she
talks about cases where know what is law
so Aristotle says he talks about this in
terms of we have the general universal
right and what tells you that reason or
your your proper upbringing or habits or
something along those so you know what
you ought to do so what they actually
makes you do yeah well it could be what
he calls an appetite goodie anger
when she treats differently than the
other appetites and emotions it's kind
of a curious thing for him
we remember playing with it too that
they don't have food most of the
spirited part of the solo part that we
can angry without it was different than
just the rest of the appetites and these
talks about uses the term opinion in
this transmission these will often can
work together so you can know what the
right thing to do yes but you must wrong
the appetite to do the wrong thing and
what does it amputated he talks about
those we're talking about confidence in
qualifying li yes to do the punish what
are the basic pleasures that are solved
except astronomers before what are the
first
we're drinking sex yeah these are very
basic and he's you know again you look
at any culture look at any time we look
at people anywhere you go once we
radically change into nature and these
will be fundamental drivers he also
talks about so how does the temperance
work in those sort of cases you know
that you shouldn't have with the desert
you all gotta have you know sort of
fancy penis right where you go home for
for vacation and it's gonna be
thanksgiving and christmas is coming up
as well we're often happens to people
weight flies over over Thanksgiving to
New Year's the Gateway what know ends in
yeah you know yeah why do what's what's
different about and very often you know
tradition
my family at Christmastime we have
oyster soup
and we have Tootsie is a French meat pie
and we have a boost in a well there's a
big log cake but not enough everybody
likes the log kick so there's other
desserts and it's you know nosh all day
long right it's a very for Thanksgiving
and you know this is the way we show
people hospitality right offer them food
and drink and you know if you want to
maintain a diet or something like that
you would be telling yourself I can't
count all of this and you may actually
feel yourself you know when you're
reaching for that third dessert saying
you know this is actually unreasonable I
don't need three desserts I mean even in
the second one flap the pleasure over
we're masters now if that happens all
the time you're vicious if you think
that that's the right thing to do you're
vicious but the the the incontinent
person they know it's the wrong thing
but they find themselves I have to do it
because the the pleasure takes over
momentarily and we'll look at how the
reasoning process works with this sex is
another great example to and the culture
that we create canvas we have managed to
remove most of the boundaries that were
in place for the Western culture
hundreds of years maybe it's a thousand
years so if you get constantly placed in
the situation where you probably
shouldn't you know get involved with
this person or that person
but it's tempting and there's nothing
else you know other than your conscience
or you know sort of general sense of
rationality saying you shouldn't do this
it will probably be difficult to resist
right especially when you're constantly
being bombarded with images about how
how much fun everybody else is having
you know we're in a society now where
the pressures to be in countenance it
needs to be in moderate are much higher
than they were just a generation I know
because I was I grew up twenty years
apart from you guys and I can look at
how things are for you and how things
work for me it was stronger for our
definition that was redundant vice versa
so it'd be very easy to be incontinent
when it comes to sex this is also one
that can get you in a lot more direct
trauma to the right
quicker than food or drink of waiting
pain people often you know they know
that they should do this they should
with this pain but they were over with
that's so they they do so that's the
case were the appetizer order masters
most other appetites what for other
things that Aristotle says we we want we
desire and they there's a lot of ways to
make a buck and some of them are as a
result says honorable and some of them
are not so honorable we talked about
this we looked at the virtues and vices
so how you use greedy greedy people
really like well and they're convinced
that that's what they want to have
wealth and possessions you can find
yourself very easily in many situations
where you know that you shouldn't take
the money or you shouldn't pursue this
opportunity or you shouldn't make this
deal but it's very tempting to do so and
again we live in a society where you're
be encouraged to do that very often and
there's a lot of little traps out there
set to do that you do think for example
look left picture let's think of a
larger scale trapping them in a small
scale trap one that you definitely won't
fall for one that you might fall they
both have to do with the internet you're
all familiar with the Nigerian banking
scam emails there's like a lot of
variations of these how do they
one day Jamie but Fred actually got an
email
yeah and you know talking about it
because they're saying oh if you send us
this amount of money we can give you
like anything goes like you're bouncing
ology you need $10,000 in the u.s. yeah
money back the oldest one is $10,000 in
gold that was it yeah the oldest one is
actually like you know I'm finding this
Nigerian Minister my money is quite a
bank here I needed to put in a US bank
I'd like to use your accounts that you
just give me your account number
I'm putting you know several dollars in
there and I'll give you a tender and not
a lot of people fall for those there's a
lot of those sorts of things
what about all these little
opportunities that exist that I'm not
arresting you shouldn't do anything so
I'm just saying you should you should be
prudent about these not necessarily your
desire for wealth which is
understandable overmaster reason what
about all these little opportunities to
you know get a little price cut here get
a coupon here that required me to get
all sorts of information
dude if you look at some of those deals
and that really deals are they and you
could think this out you could actually
be you know you have to click on stuff
get to look at what the terms of the
Whomper arm you could actually look at
that but you could at least in that
moment or characteristically five years
they'll say you know I really want this
deal
I really have to have this important
think about the grocery store as well
sometimes it's hard to resist
two-for-one lagers isn't it even though
you don't actually need two of those I
went to Sam's Club yeah there was
two-for-one packs of tortillas big
hundred corn tortillas and we were
making something with tortillas and I
only took one and I got to the front
register and she would ring it up for me
because that didn't have you know - they
couldn't they literally couldn't really
focus - for one this is a computer
dimension but it shows you you know this
this sort of mentality we are very
walking in confidence when it comes to
well if you're walking by the gas
station counter and you find yourself
buying a lighter because the later you
know attractive you know that's more use
of what we call impulse buy right
impulse buying
of incontinence if you're doing it all
the time if you think that's the right
thing to do that would actually be
vicious
because it's not another good thing it's
a very small place but if you're doing
it then afterwards you regret it then
you're probably incontinent well so well
you talk about gain gain is pretty much
the same thing as well what are the
things that leads have to get led astray
by good things even honorable things
decent things not always the right thing
for us sometime
link it back to when we talked about the
candidates for happiness
remember with some of the other
candidates besides
yeah
yeah yeah very good
believe it or not you get caught in
situations where seeking honor is
actually the one thing to do it all
depends on how you can see the honor or
respect or those sorts of concepts but
there can be situations where being
honorable might interfere with say being
just or being ten threats or even being
kind and you can be even tempered with
respect to that because we do see there
are there are some people who are more
ambitious with respect to honor it's
more of a problem area for anything else
omega-t have that's not just a pleasure
or things like that
aerosol says one other thing this is one
you can probably relate to picture
winning how many of you have been in an
argument and you said something in the
argument they hit cheap shot you know
dig at somebody and you won the argument
as a result
any of you ever done that well
Aristotle calls people like that feeling
echoes they like they are attracted to
who they have as a designer winning not
Charlie Sheen kind of man which is very
ambiguous losing ends up being winning
right but actually win it you know how
this manifests for me we're talking
about driving before a few of you may
relate to this
I like passing how many of you like to
like passing am I the only one yeah I
actually get a charge up and when I
realized that you know it took a long
time for actually realize that this is
the case yes it sort of felt it for a
while but it's not always the best thing
you know get yourself into lots of
situations each day where you can try to
get that little extra person and want
them it doesn't even work because we're
out here to do something stoplights
right so you you pass the person look
kid the same stoplight
you didn't actually gain anything that's
the type of being motivated by the
desire to the submit and if you're doing
it too risky circumstances again you're
probably incontinent then you probably
want to take a look at that so you don't
get yourself to the point where you
justify it to yourself so many times
that you actually become vicious you all
know people more ambitious with
responsibly
a motivational factor right that's all
they seem to care about when you
approach them about that they say you'd
only think that cuz you're a loser
you know a winner like me that would be
a sign of being vicious again it's very
easy to make that transition
my main anchor is really interesting
because aerosol treats that differently
than he does all these other emotions
he's even got a section where he talks
about why losing your temper and acting
on that is not as bad as following any
of these stuff probably not really good
advice to get anybody who has an anger
problem
because now you just told them that what
they're doing is more or less okay but
if say says incontinence and respect
that the anger is less disgraceful than
that in respect to the appetites angular
seems to listen to argument to some
extent but to miscarry here's got a
great assuming as hasty servants who run
out before they heard the whole of what
one says or there's dogs bark if there's
but it knocked at the door before I'm
looking to see with it so anger is kind
of indiscriminate you guys all have two
experiences when you get angry what
happens to how do you begin to approach
the world differently there's that none
of you literally see whole world turns
right there are some people
what happens psychologically to you it
kind of tunnel vision so suddenly things
that worked so important assume great
importance you have to the system this
point they have to understand this
before we proceed any further yeah you
have this feeling wishing the other
person ill and you know aristotle
doesn't say this but other moral
philosophers say this that anger that
goes on long enough will actually become
hate anger kind of takes us away it sets
us on a trajectory and it becomes very
difficult to get out as a matter of fact
some of the people who've studied anger
and realize things like if you want to
get yourself calm down you can go off
and do something else and if you do it
for about 10 20 minutes and you're doing
consistently you will actually find
yourself getting calmer if however you
allow yourself to think about the thing
that you're angry about it will not help
you will be just as angry so if you're
thinking about that person what a jerk
they were and who are they to say that
sort of thing you will continue to stay
anger and the angry person very often
tends to do that because you know being
in the right about these sorts of things
anger is about being the right you get
angry when you feel that somebody has
blogged you they didn't have any good
reason to do that and you feel yourself
to be in the right who wants some sort
of you know revenge so like he says you
know it's it's like reason except it
only business to have the story then
once you start listening to only half
the story that continues to only this is
half the story so you know the angel
person well they're acting that there
could be two cases they could be acting
that they're sort of in control being
controlled by anger angers and control
of that and then afterwards that realize
what they did sure smart can't that
person should follow excuse but it does
tell why that actually occurred there
can be cases where you're angry and as
you're doing things by angry you know
that they're wrong to do but you still
find yourself sort of gripped by the
anger
she says argument or imagination informs
us that we've been insulted or slighted
anger reasoning as it were that anything
like this must be fought against boils
up straight away we're at the site if
argument a perception said of knowledge
it is pleasant springs up to the
enjoyment of it so anger obeys the
argument that the sense but appetite
actually doesn't what he means by the
argument is the argument but what we
ought to do that's good and then he says
we parted people more easily for
following natural desires and here's
something that missus is very
interesting
anger is one of our most natural desires
anger is one of our most natural
emotions Aristotle says we could contest
that maybe that may be what he said that
it's a really desire though and you know
how to sense a natural emotion book yes
I mean that's a good question desire
angers and this is sort of a digression
myself very interested Aristotle defines
a lot of the emotions in terms of
desires some of them are just responses
like joy or sadness or miss responses
anger involved anger is very complicated
and Aristotle's good for getting at this
anger involves a form of pain pain of
being or something it also involves
actually an anticipation of pleasure in
getting what it wants what it wants is
what he calls a parent or a public
retribution or punishment or however you
want to translate this
sometimes you can say revenge against
the person who the angry person feels
wrong about so anger actually is game
anger does involve a desire a desire for
retribution that's why we often do get
calm when we see the other person
doesn't always even have to be oestrogen
hurting it could be you're angry at the
president because the president did
something that you can't stand and then
you see something else okay doesn't have
to be you necessarily but there has to
be something that sort of tips the
balance that whites the scales that's
what the angry person so it doesn't want
a signer
now whether whether we are as human
beings more naturally inclined anger
than other things I don't know I think
that's very debatable pleasure
attractions you know some of you were
putting yourself to go to school
probably not right all of you I think
wanted respect I don't know yes
so a more natural
he also says those who are more giving
the plotting against so there's a
criminal a passionate man is not given
apply ignore his anger itself it is both
one of the good things one of the few
good things about the anger is that it
latest stuff not on the table you get
somebody angry and you do in fact find
out a lot of things about what they
actually do it do things some of its
imagine some of it's actually Bria
so aerosol says it's actually how does
it made out to be in content with
respect to anger as it is with respect
to uses I think in our society we treat
it differently yeah they may be
President but yeah the courts can
actually be ending anger-management
classes where does that appear a lot of
stuff like what aerosol was talking
about Epictetus he also talks about one
other thing that's that's kind of
interesting how acting and anger is not
necessarily the same thing as being
vicious it says no one commits want an
outrage why not rages would help means
to be cruel to another person with a
feeling of the pain but people are cruel
to other people that why do they do it
because they get a kick out of it they
enjoy it they they feel the good feeling
hurting somebody else does they have the
case for the the angry
they feel pain when they where they feel
angry so Aristotle thinks that no if you
do that often enough the light with any
other types of incontinence if you allow
yourself to lose your temper over and
over and over again remember there was a
virtue and vice associated with anger
right good temper and there are all
those different types of going wrong for
bad temper so if you do this flop it
enough then you will reach the point
where you start telling yourself things
like you're always justified when you're
feeling angry then you will feel more
and more of that thriller and some
people actually become addicted to anger
they need to get angry so we have a few
minutes left let's look at the other
reasoning process afterwards so what's
going on over here in one part of the
ermine news item is we have a general
principle that's telling you you should
do this so how do you end up doing the
appetite says people show
the reasoning process there's sort of
two reasoning processes going on in your
head at the same time you know appetite
says you should pursue pleasant things
that's saying that all the time you
should pursue pleasant things you should
pursue pleasant things and if it's a
particular appetite is saying you
shouldn't eat you know tasty food you
should eat tasty food this is going on
in the back of your your mind you need
to think about it order to say in your
body constantly right and this is part
of what it is to be a human being it's
also part of what it is to be animals
nice things to do right and you can do
this with sense or touch or hearing or
anything like that
once you've been exposed to something
pleasant you want that pleasant thing
again you know you're kind of music that
you like you never sort of the appetite
and sometimes it's stronger sometimes
it's weaker but it's like a constant in
you should do this you should go do this
you actually see something that's
Pleasant
you know that's Pleasant yeah before
let's take the desert for example right
anybody doesn't like chocolate there are
a few people who don't like each other
but not about this class so if I were to
like it I'll take a really nice I would
use a chocolate bar
never to put it right here that those of
you know wouldn't have your site locked
out of the students Iraq you know you're
all filing out of the room you would be
tempted to take that chocolate none of
you are right if I only have one and I
put it right here but I need would take
it because all of you are pretty well
behaved well brought up individuals we
have some degree of self control but
what if it was a classroom that somebody
just left a chocolate there we're like
let's say a whole bunch of chocolate
bars over a box of news about there's
you know doing their selling thing and
that's the last class of the day
nobody's claimed it yeah
they be attempting to take a lot of
those chocolate was tasty right yeah but
the same to be telling you to take
chocolate I'm just gonna miss it it's
sort of like you know the devil right
meanwhile if you still have something
going out in the back of your head this
way you're not vicious saying you
shouldn't take that why shouldn't you
take it because it's not yours you
shouldn't take things that are not yours
that's carrying out practical reasoning
too so you have two different courses of
practical reasoning what tips the skills
to take is strong you feel appetite so
you do with anger it's a little bit
different like like yourself said anger
here's the reason when you talked about
being a consultant
well the dangers a little different you
have this this again part of your human
nature when insulted everyone should
take revenge that's sort of the
principle underlying how anger works if
you don't take any revenge or feel any
bad feelings when you're insulted in
aerosol actually says there's something
wrong with you but it's a question of
you know how we do it right people
so let's not insulted me where do we
often go wrong with anger there's this
did they actually absoulte you how many
times we take offense at people where no
offense was actually intended wait
writing is a great example of that you
know the person who is driving a fermion
some people try to go in front of me
when I can't pass them and I feel
thankfully that anger and I feel like
they're wronging to me by being in my
way they're taking up the public road
space that belongs to all of us by God
why don't they get out of our way so
people who actually have somewhere to
get to can get by them and get to where
they need to go that's a little does
this sound familiar
you ever feel something like this well
that's that's a case where anger is
suggesting a course of action you know
and then when you go around them what
are you tempted to do once you actually
pass them what's that then it might
speed up and we'll show you people do
all sorts of things they they pass them
and then they cut them off and then they
go real slow I'm gonna show you what
it's like well what is really saying is
that smart is that a good thing of you
you're driving at you know one ton of
piece of metal or else that's only
controlled by this you know this this
steering is it smart to do those sorts
of things no it's bad idea
so what wreath or what anger is
suggesting goes against what reason is
he's telling you yeah if you're gonna
follow that case
confidence anger is blinding it as we
say and then afterwards you may feel
foolish if you don't feel bad about it
afterwards that's probably a sign that
you're becoming vicious with respect and
pretty soon you're gonna find yourself
doing all sorts of things as a country
person and saying that it's okay so
those are the reasoning process is
taking place a lot less murky than what
Aristotle himself was saying the when
he's talking about sweet things must be
tasted and here's the particular
universal this is what he's talking
about there yeah the thing they want to
talk about it's easy to kind of figure
it out because you only have one hand
side when you take it or you don't
with doing you take half of it take
having a brief thought that take it or
not
yeah you know with anger there's so many
ways they handle even one issues such as
passing somebody or not passing somebody
else is a fraction of it I mean you can
you know be like you know there's so
many ways that you know it's not really
wrong but you know can be yeah I mean
I'll grant you that in those cases that
we picked out there are a lot of
alternatives for the driving one there's
only one range of
we can think of other cases where
amethyst where there could be a whole
range of possibilities like you know for
instance you're out at the farm yeah
you're actually gonna have a
relationship but you know it's not
really that solid yeah and you're not
quite sure but you suspect that you are
and there's somebody interactive at the
end of the bar that you could you could
you know get involved with and people
will go through all sorts of mental
generations as well you know they're
just gonna make out with that car that's
cheating
there's this line that can be drawn out
of this line and that's why I'm not sure
if I'm I mean you could actually here to
do one thing you could actually call the
person who you're involved with up and
say I'm really exclusive because I got
kind of a situation to resolve here your
practical reason this whole range of
other things you know there could be the
range of follow what reason dictates you
do that by turning a chair not allowing
yourself to be distracted by that person
do you go up to them and have a
conversation with them just to make sure
that you can
get yourself through it there's a lot of
possibilities alright so so there my
point is it's the situation that will
tell us how many possibilities for
action there it's not necessarily just
anger anymore well they're going to be
like all sorts of possibilities now I
won't talk very quickly about
brutishness so Aristotle says there can
be cases where a person just can't
choose where we wouldn't hold them
responsible and he doesn't totally get
the person off the hook he says that
that brutishness or brutality is
actually more more terrible more scary
more appalling but that advice with Vice
the person could do otherwise but they
have gotten themselves in the situation
with respect to the character where
they're not going to do otherwise let's
use for example murderers or even worse
murderer - murderer rapists someone who
likes to teach yeah some of them like
one guy could really you know really
have a lot of sympathy to this day he
wasn't another man he was twenty years
old
raped and killed his wife and he knew
that this guy probably was not going to
get caught and was not very good
sentence he knew who did it
so he went and killed him himself and
because he because there was an interval
they decided to go to murder one and so
he did 20 years 50 years sentence in
Indiana get time cuts for various things
that guy acted really if I was placed in
that situation
very hard time not doing something
similar to what he did I think that's
not at all
that's that's in consonance with respect
to hangers he wasn't a vicious guy now
there's people who are vicious there are
you know there were guys in there who
would kill witnesses teach a lot former
gang members yeah some of them were
people who'd like to kill people yeah so
you want to keep those those four people
in prison as long as you can unless they
better change they don't be vicious but
they could still recognize that at least
society thought that was wrong and they
better not follow their appetites that
much then there's people who you know
like hurting and killing people and
there's nothing you could recently
there's no better part and those are the
people who are really scary really
dangerous
not every cases is that extreme talks
about a lot of other cases like that and
what might we put on that that you think
about a lot of in our society the person
who is completely addicted to some sort
of say a hard drug like heroin means the
sort of things that really ladle out you
know if you're addicted to tobacco you
can stop your slumbers this morning I
can't you you get the patch you make
choices you are
and it really hurts when you have to
quit smoking it's a strong creative but
if you're addicted to heroin that's very
different immune and getting nothing
done when so many forces you into the
clinic it makes you do it that's very
complicated that happen and you look at
all sorts of things in order to make the
money that's required in order to get
their own to do that at certain point
alcoholism does that people drink long
enough eventually it works out larger
portions of their brain and they just
can't function that would be the case of
what he's calling brittish's in that
case it doesn't make any sense to talk
about voluntary and involuntary but this
is irresponsible point I'm not saying
you necessarily have to have this
position there's something no longer
human about that they sort of descended
to the level of purity unavailable
what's really interesting in here in
this section I was reading it through
this time I had about this before
aerosol actually talks about the effects
of sex abuse he's got a line in there
he's talking about different reasons why
somebody might end up having some
compulsion within them that they simply
cannot avoid meeting and it could
you know deviance it's a pleasure that
most people don't take pleasure in but
this person does and he talks about
those financial life he talks about yeah
he says others other brutish States of
rise as the result of disease or the
suffocates madness some of them are
rising from custom in here if you're in
a situation where everybody around you
is screwed up you're probably going to
end up as well if you grew up in a
society where it's common to throw
children and it's like dogs or something
like that you're probably going to have
a very low opinion of them life but then
he says these are rice or some by nature
and others as in those who have been the
victims of lost from childhood by heaven
and this is what I'm going to leave you
my my mentor who was actually not just a
philosophy professor who's also a
practicing counseling commissioner who
works with abused children in class one
day we were discussing a different
philosophy he said that what's really
bad about a child childhood sexual abuse
is that it radically rearranges
evaporating the child's understanding of
what the good is it doesn't just do it
intellectually it does it
habits of character in cases like that
Aristotle would say perhaps we can't
actually hold that person accountable
the way we would other doesn't mean that
we can't that pretty result doesn't mean
that we can't say what they're doing is
wrong but it means that their structure
of motivation would be very different
much more like that'll be yeah in case
of certain types of sexual abuse that
does seem to be the case so I'll leave
you on that see you on Thursday